breaking tonight Fox News has learned
President Trump is expected to commute
Roger stone sentence just days before
stone is set to report to prison for
charges stemming from the Muller
investigation White House correspondent
Kevin cork live for us in Washington
Kevin evening Trey says the president
left the White House and roots of
Florida for a series of events today he
was actually asked about the prospect of
issuing that pardon to stone who as you
know was convicted in a trial last year
of lying to Congress and witness
tampering
he is 67 he now faces three years four
months behind bars the president has
been talking a lot about this topic
recently and here's what he told
reporters today I'll be looking at it I
think Roger stone was very unfairly
treated as were many people and in the
meantime Comey and all these guys are
walking around including Biden and Obama
because we caught them spying on my
campaign who would have believed that
one president was actually pushed
further on this topic last night in an
exclusive interview here on Fox
I am always thinking I am always
thinking like everybody else in this
case speaking there to Sean Hannity now
for his part the Attorney General of the
United States bill Barr has according to
sources asked the president to shred
lightly with respect to stone after all
in his opinion there was nothing wrong
with the 40 months sentence handed down
in his case he left it to the judge and
she imposed the sentence that I actually
thought was reasonable now the president
for those of you keeping score has
actually issued nine commutations during
his time in office including four of
them in February among them
rod Blagojevich and Tracy I can tell you
we've just actually received word that
stones appeal has been denied his appeal
that is to push back his reporting date
to jail right now he's supposed to
report to the prison on July the 14th
that is of course best deal day he was
hoping to push that back because of
Kovach concerns maybe to September that
request has been denied we'll see if or
when the president decides to issue a
commutation trace we will indeed Kevin
live for us in Washington Kevin thank
you